alright guys bangbang
I have Kathy here with us this is her
second appearance on the podcast
I don't ever admit this usually but she
her first conversation with me was my
favorite episode ever and when I told
people that she was coming back on many
people were tweeting at me saying that
this was their favorite episode as well
so no pressure we'll see if we can do it
again awesome
listen you've been doing this for a long
time this is not your first radio not
your first economic crisis let's just
start with given the historical context
and all the experience you have like
what is going on now and should people
be worried or not right
well thank you Tom very much for your
kind words and for inviting me back yes
I have been in the business for more
than 40 years I started when I was in
college and so I've been through ten
crises if you include recessions and
this appears to me to be like two of
them and the two were shocks shocks to
the system unexpected sudden the first
one was when portfolio insurance failed
in October of 87 and created black
Monday that's when the stock market
dropped by almost 25 percent in one day
that didn't happen this time around and
quite simply those who thought they
could get out of the market because they
were insured they that insurance failed
and so it caused all kinds of concerns
about systemic effects and so forth
instead you know what happened was the
people who had bought portfolio
insurance were the losers this was a
shock people were waiting around
thinking okay is this gonna have
reverberations beyond this and as it
turned out it didn't so forces in motion
before that shock continued in motion
the 80s was a great bull market and that
continued
the second time many people think it's
Oh 809 no it's not that was a true
financial crisis meltdown this is a
shock it's a health care crisis which
has financial ramifications but it's a
shock to the system and so in 911 shock
to the system then we're in the middle
of the tech and telecom bust everyone
was waiting around to see okay is this
systemic in terms of 911 more terrorist
attacks and so forth it wasn't and
forces emotion state of motion the tech
and telecom bust continued for another
18 months this time around we were in a
very strong economy and in fact it was
much stronger than what people perceive
it to have been now and the reason for
that is in both China and the US the
consumer was really strong and in the
u.s. in particular the consumer also had
a large buffer and 8% saving rate which
has doubled over the last I'm going to
say 10 years so an 8% saving rate nice
buffer consumer spending very strong but
businesses were pulling back and they
had been pulling back for 18 months
because of the china-us trade conflict
and because of inverted yield curves
which businesses were sure we're going
to trigger a recession well that is not
what triggered the recession and I'm not
even sure that this will in hindsight be
considered a recession we'll see I'm
seeing numbers a recession the official
definition is back-to-back quarters of
negative GDP looks like first quarter
will be up looks like second quarter
will be down big and the question is
will we be down in the third not sure
about that depends on how fast we get
back to work so I believe that forces in
motion before this crisis will continue
in motion we will end up in more of a
v-shaped recovery I think and most
people believe because of the setup the
consumer was strong had a nice buffer
savings buffer cos had already pulled
back and if the consumer comes back
businesses are going to have to race to
catch up to the consumer yeah and so how
do you take some of the data points that
we're seeing so we've got I think about
16 17 million Americans who have filed
for unemployment last three weeks right
on top of the 5.8 million or so at the
end of February there were unemployed so
call it you know 28 and 22 million is
kind of the official number obviously
that there's some under counting that
probably goes on there then you see
things like I think there's a Wall
Street Journal article that said a third
of renters didn't pay rent right and you
know I'm probably with you and that you
could question the accuracy of some of
the surveys and things like that but
it's a bigger number than I think most
of us expected is that kind of temporary
type pain that the consumer or the
average citizen experiences or is there
something that potentially you could get
economic gain in the third quarter and
then you get the consumer those still
suffers a little bit like how do you
think through that yeah well in terms of
the numbers I heard today on CNBC the
CEO of related which has widespread real
estate holdings so he gave numbers
through through the yesterday and in his
complex of them multi-dwelling
homes he said ninety percent of those
people are paying their rent which was
higher than he expected in commercial
real estate again this is one company
but has very broad base a hundred
percent are paying rent
and the biggest laggard is retail you
know though the retailers are on paper
thin margins so only a third of his
retail tenants are paying rent whereas I
think for the nation it's more like down
to 20% so there's the weak link right
there right and a lot of the people who
are out of work are from bricks and
mortar in more mom-and-pop small
businesses so yes we I've been I
been surprised at how much work is
taking place digitally our our business
has not skipped a beat not a beat and in
fact I think we're so much more
productive now in some ways than we are
on a day to day basis maybe I was
speaking for myself I don't know so I
think we're going to we're going to see
an accelerated shift into a non like
online work situation which ultimately
could hurt commercial but in terms of
the next half year I think everybody I
think the the Trump administration the
task force in particular every day
reassuring the nation saying this is
gonna be temporary there's gonna be and
we're looking for now most people don't
believe Trump when he says well this is
gonna be the sharpest most vigorous but
they have to take into consideration
that that could happen and that if they
start doing stupid things like shutting
down they'll be deprived of a big whip I
think that's been very important yeah
you know faster including for including
you know we had labor shortages before
labor shortages so I I think I think
we're gonna come out of this faster than
most people expect yeah and one of the
things you're kind of hinting at here is
there's a couple people who started to
say look the virus may actually be an
accelerant on the way into the economic
shock obviously right a there were some
issues we're now seeing some of that
accelerated but it may also be an
accelerant in terms of other trends so
things like remote work a lot of
technology enabled things it sounds like
you're you know pretty strong in that
camp of believing that coming out of
this those trends just now are more
likely to occur happen faster than they
already we're on pace to do yeah so I
started arc in 2014 and we've probably
had five significant risk off risk on
periods and during each of those periods
I would I would lend perspective to our
young analyst team and say look I've
been through a lot of crises innovation
gains market share at an accelerated
rate in a crisis why better cheaper
faster more productive more creative new
products and services to
health problems and I think that's true
here I think this is you know we're at
what I often call the sweet spot of the
s-curve just entering the steepest part
even for online retail I think many
people are surprised given our own
habits to learn that online retail in
the United States is still only 15% of
total retail sales now I think in all of
our lives is gone up to the majority of
sales if I if I or maybe not majority of
non grocery sales I even groceries are
now coming online in a bigger way thanks
to Whole Foods Amazon and so forth so I
think some of the trends in motion that
we thought we thought were just entering
the sweet spot of the s-curve for retail
I think I think this is accelerated it
as it has for online education which is
not at the sweet spot but is definitely
a trend telemedicine when you get
Medicare reimbursing telemedicine you
know you're you're onto something big so
tell a doc their online education to you
and you know these stocks have been
affected in different ways tell a doc
has held up beautifully it went out to
an all-time high and we've tended to
sell those stocks in favor of a company
like to you which because of its low
cash buffer and high cash burn it's in a
high investment phase of its life
algorithms out there
these are mindless algorithms all they
do in a crisis is say okay two things
matter low cash buffer hi cash burn and
they go out and they kill those stocks
so - you went from $30 to 11 and a half
in two weeks that's nuts
that's nuts when it's one of the
solutions to the problem you know that
we're facing out there so you know we
were looking around for those sorts of
names which we know are going to be able
to access the capital markets if they
need it because it's so clear there a
solution to the problem yeah let's talk
a little bit about kind of the health
crisis first and then we'll get into the
economic and policies and things there
the virus has shut down entire societies
for any countries etc what's kind of
your take on is the health crisis
weren't it in the sense of the response
we have on the health side are we doing
enough not enough kind of how do you
think through that yeah you know there
have been two other corona viruses
circulating through our economy for on a
regular basis their annual now they're
part of now our annual flu season
so this corona virus is different in
that it's much more contagious but much
less deadly right so but when you put
those two together the much more
contagious it could it could hit a lot
more people much less lethal well maybe
it maybe it would be typical flu like
numbers which are anywhere from in the
United States 30,000 to 70,000 a year
now it looks like this one's going to
kill maybe 60,000 and I guess that's the
only number we can really count on
because we don't know how many people
really have been infected two people in
my in my sphere meaning my household and
household help have been infected so I I
think you know when books are written
about this we'll say okay well okay that
was an overreaction and yes there there
there there there are there is a group
of people that we must protect when
something is that contagious even if it
is less lethal and in this case it was
the those with other lung compromised
diseases as well as maybe people with
high blood pressure we're not sure about
that one yet so and you know a couple of
things are happening because of this
virus first of all we could not have
sequenced it in two days China sequenced
it in two days it took us five months to
sequence the SARS virus back in no three
so that that happened very quickly now
China probably knew the sequence
my guess is well before they shared it
with us
and if we had had it sooner we would
have understood it better but now I
think the other thing that we're
learning the tests that Abbott and
Cepheid which is owned by Danaher have
put out and I know Cepheid well because
I owned it before Danaher bought it and
really really good company they they're
actually based on old old-time PCR
technology it's old technology but what
got them to market as fast as they could
get to market were two things first of
all the sequencing of the virus we
understand exactly what it is and we
understand how it's mutating to that's
thanks to companies like Illumina and
then the second is synthetic biology so
if sequencing is the ability to read the
DNA of a virus synthetic biology is the
ability to write the DNA of a virus and
that company is twist it's one of the
most advanced out there not many people
know it but it's an amazing company if
they have not done those two things
Abbott and and Cepheid wouldn't have
been able to develop the test as quickly
as they have so that's good and I think
the other thing that's coming out of
this there are two other things from a
healthcare point of view after so the
SARS epidemic in o3 it circled the world
and then went poof it disappeared unlike
the other corona viruses I mentioned to
you and so what happened during SARS
that was a crisis I mean miss thing was
Mars was the lethality of SARS was at
least 10 percent Ebola was gosh it was
you know well above 50 percent and MERS
was somewhere in between there so again
this is much less deadly we don't know
how deadly it is because we don't know
how many people have gotten it will
after the fact so back then SARS
vaccines like there was so much money
pushed into the development of vaccines
it went poof and the funding for
vaccines dried up and then nobody wanted
to be in vaccines all these big pharma
companies sold their vaccine companies
because they were money pits right now
again and we're now that we have new
technologies like Madonna and inovio and
our tourists Moderne and our tourists
are based on RNA technology anova on DNA
technology RNA we've never seen at work
if it works it's going to be amazing and
it'll be a very profitable it's going to
be a winner take most you know because
these companies have developed libraries
of data and are going to be able to at
least get the licensing fees royalties
on all of this so I think royal vaccine
is going to be a good place to be and
the other thing I think that this
healthcare crisis has done has is its
providing a lot of political cover what
politician is going to say no I don't
want to pay for testing for this that or
the other disease or I don't want to pay
for vaccines you know we're not gonna
put that in the budgets no testing which
has also been it's considered
historically a commoditized business and
and you have two big companies
dominating you have quest and lab Cork
in in the old world and it's mostly
commoditized even their esoteric tests
become commoditized just because they're
so big and now what's happening is you
get a company like in vitae or Gardens
or Personalis some of these you may have
heard of what they are doing I think
this is gonna be a winner take most
world like so many in the artificial
intelligence world they are gathering
all the data they have harnessed
geneticists throughout the world
you know these pools of geneticists and
they are beginning to develop tests
that are very precise and because they
can they've collected the right kind of
data so I think they're going to have so
much more political cover than they have
had historically it's always been an
area starved of funding because everyone
assumes it's commoditized it's not we
have the convergence of DNA sequencing
artificial intelligence and then CRISPR
gene editing which is going to not only
not only will we be able to create these
text tests so that to understand in a
very personal way how your DNA is
influenced right and and what is
impacted what's what your D how your DNA
is mutating they'll be able to figure
that out and then they'll be able to
pull therapies off the shelf or they'll
be able to design them with gene editing
to actually cure or reprogram your DNA
and cure the disease that's where we're
going yeah it's super exciting to see
kind of the healthcare side and I think
that the idea of a vaccine or cure is a
health component but it's also a
psychological component what people know
that's out there I think that changes
the mindset what is your thoughts about
the economic cure right so we kind of
have a health crisis that's causing an
economic crisis or kind of a shock as
you described it there's a lot of
economic policies that have been
implemented what's kind of your general
view of what's already been done it
maybe even what needs to be done in the
future right so you know my mentor is
art Laffer I don't know if you're
familiar with the Laffer curve
supply-side economics but he advises
Trump president Trump informally
regularly and I know because I hear
during the task force briefings I hear
some of the things that art Laffer says
coming out of President Trump's mouth in
the beginning art was very frustrated
that they were just throwing money at
this just willy-nilly and effectively
effectively throwing money at the idea
that we don't want people to work
and from from one point of view that was
correct we wanted people if they could
to work from home of course but we
wanted them to be safe first and
foremost they had as so the the programs
that were being designed in the early
days and we're just throw the money at
them have been modified so that you're
seeing more in the form of loans to
small businesses and others that will
have to be repaid after a long grace
period so that is good just to keep the
infrastructure in place to keep the to
allow the employment to rebound
afterwards instead of unlike in a recent
recession where you have capital
destruction you it takes a long time to
work through it and then to come back so
I think that's good I think it's good
that they are sending checks out to
those who can who are living paycheck to
paycheck but I think a more important
way to help those people and would have
the same effect would be to say and I've
heard president Trump mention it it
hasn't been put into any legislation yet
to basically go on a payroll tax holiday
both both for the employers and the
employees through the end of the year
what would that do it would say it would
encourage businesses who are getting
these holidays and employees to get back
to work as quickly as it possible to
take advantage of the holiday and
increase their returns by six to seven
percent on either side that's huge
that's the tax wedge that art Laffer
talks about all the time if you get rid
of that wedge you bring a lot more
activity back much sooner than otherwise
would be the case and I think the other
in terms of the way they're treating
larger corporations I think they're
creating inducements to
back up faster what they're doing is
they're saying okay if you take these
lungs then you cannot buy buy back
shares or pay dividends for a year past
when and I don't know if the legislation
has changed your a bit but this is how
it was being written a year past the day
you repay those loans well what what
will that cause shareholders certainly
will want their companies to to get back
on track much faster so they can pay
back the loans to the government and
then get back to paying dividends which
for many people are a large chunk of
their of their income especially a
retirees and to repurchase shares which
favors all shareholders so I think
they're doing these are they're
gradually getting it right and very
sensitive you hear more and more about
and you hear certainly the president and
the vice president talking about getting
people back to work safely so you'll
have pence focused on the safety and
you'll have Trump focused on getting
back to work and it's a good dynamic and
an important dynamic I think yeah are
you worried at all you know we're in a
deflationary environment now there's a
lot of QE going on are you one worried
that we could over rotate on the
inflationary side when we switch back
and are there any impacts that you
foresee potentially on the US dollar
it's kind of a global asset or reserve
asset mm-hmm okay
so the first question and when we can
and we can take some of we can inform
the answer that question partly by what
happened after oh eight oh nine so I
remember when you know it was QE
everything you know I remembered being
concerned saying wow this is just such
an inducement to take a lot of risk and
just go out there and go for it that's
not what happened what happened was
people were so traumatized by the
breakdown of our financial and economic
system that they were not sure we were
going to be able to hold together and
you know there are all kinds of
uncertainties including what became the
election year you know we had the
European sovereign debt crisis we had in
16 oil prices crashing like they have
recently and China seeming to implode
and so every step along the way
there was a reason for people to hold
back and not throw everything that they
have at risk-taking and in fact the loss
the velocity of money which is the
critical answer here has been falling
and my guess is falling at an
accelerated rate now and so all of that
QE most of it is still sitting on the
balance sheets of central banks now the
way I think about that still is that is
kindling for the fire potential fire
that you're talking about but that
kindling hasn't been lit for the past 10
years because every step along the way
including the china-us trade conflict
and the inverted yield curves every one
of those steps along the way has been a
reason to recoil and say so the velocity
of money has continued to come down now
we have m2 today growing at a 15%
year-over-year rate which is I believe
the fastest I mean you have to go back a
lot of years to see that I think many
people have gotten used to this idea
that we can throw anything we want at
the system and velocity will fall and
offset it there will be come a day and
this could be the beginning but I don't
think it will I don't think we'll see
the ramifications in terms of inflation
for I'm going to say at least a year and
a half maybe two years because first we
still do have a little bit of this
seizing up and people saying is my job
going to be there so that's one reason
and business is the
same is my business going to exist so
again another reason if you look I just
listen to the JP Morgan call this
morning and you know so many businesses
have taken down their revolvers
completely you know so they are just
awash in cash their own wash in cash and
they did the same thing in a 809 but
again nothing happened everybody being
scared every step along the way so the
reason we won't have an inflation
problem for the next 18 months two years
there are two reasons one oil prices
have crashed and oil is a big part of
you know the input and and there's a
good reason secularly for oil to crash
we talk about it all the time
I think oils going down longer term to
ten dollars or less per barrel and I've
been saying that for a while that's a
personal point of view and that's
because of electric vehicles and
autonomous electric vehicles at the
margin gas powered cars are going to
start losing out and commodity prices
are determined at the margin that's what
a lot of people miss when they say oh
well electric vehicles are only 2% of
all sales no they're a much higher
percentage of the growth in the auto
industry right so so the first reason is
that major input to so many industries
the second is typically if we're going
to have a v-shaped recovery what will
happen is productivity will search now
productivity was already starting to
search so again this idea forces in
motion continue in motion I think the
accelerated shift into new technologies
now is going to cause an acceleration in
productivity growth we're probably going
to see productivity growth numbers in
the next year that we haven't seen I'm
gonna say since the sixties so that's
that's another reason productivity is a
huge force against inflation because why
because a company which benefits from
productivity can do three things with it
it can increase wages so if they if come
if companies have late
shortages they will increase wages but
not now nobody has labor shortage
because the unemployment rate is going
to go to 15 percent or whatever or
higher it can go to lower prices to
compete and bring consumers back and to
compete against China because China is
using innovation and deflation to
compete so that's another thing that
could happen here which would reinforce
this disinflationary cycle or it can go
to increase profit margins and it's
probably going to depending on the
industry going to go to all three so I
don't think what's the inflation in the
near term I do worry about it now that
no one thinks it's possible anymore I
remember starting in the business that
was the late 70s I was in college and I
remember looking at these CPI numbers
that were coming out and economists
didn't didn't believe them because they
thought inflation had been licked
then when really it had just started
because we went off the gold exchange
standard in 1971 but no one could
believe the numbers we were seeing and
that's because they had been lulled into
complacency that the Fed could do
anything it wanted well I think that
we're back in that situation but we will
not face and I know where you're going
with this obviously a bit point we won't
face the real ramifications for another
couple of years but you know I know
we've increased our Bitcoin exposure
where in the discretionary portfolios at
arc and I think I think it's the right
thing to do from an insurance policy
point of view yeah well we'll never get
a get too big quote for sure well one of
the things I want to talk about before
is let's just talk about innovation in a
time of crisis first and then we can
kind of go through a number of either
different investments or industries I
know you guys are interested in and
we'll finish up with Bitcoin but when it
comes to innovation you said a number of
times now that innovation was like
steals market share during these times
of crisis right and technology has a
massive advantage maybe elaborate on
that a little bit and explain kind of
what you mean by that
and if you have any examples of where
that's happened before sure I'll start
out by giving you two examples from the
O 809 period since we have that data and
we don't have all the data from this
crisis yet although I can tell you from
the way our stocks are behaving the
market is beginning to understand this
whereas in oh eight oh nine if you
looked at salesforce.com you you would
have thought I was going out of business
so what happened in Oh eight oh nine I
remember listening to researchers from
GE saying you know our our tech budgets
have been shut down effectively I can't
get any of my projects done I'm using my
personal credit card to buy to pay as I
go by salesforce.com
software-as-a-service and I'll put that
in as an expense it's not a capital
spending item anymore and that was an
aha moment for me certainly so if you
look back then most software stocks
companies which had the enterprise
license model which most of them did at
the time their budgets were cut enormous
ly or they were hit badly if you look at
and and salesforce.com was just taken
down with all of them like it was the
but because it was a newbie like it was
going out of business it sold off worse
than some of the enterprise license
model players so it when you look back
on what happened there while tech buds
budgets were down twenty to thirty
percent salesforce.com was an answer to
a problem I can't afford these big
enterprise license fees the upfront fees
I can't at the end of OE I can't redo
and I have to move over to
salesforce.com pay-as-you-go and other
software as a service models Salesforce
calms worst quarter in that crisis from
the revenue growth point of view
remember people thought it was going out
of business was up 20% in the worst
crisis since the Great Depression retail
sales for many I looked at retail sales
numbers going back 208
mamako cells they were down 10 to 12
percent at their worst amazon's worst
quarter was up 14% and i think their
worst quarter this time around isn't
there's not going to be a worst quarter
their sales aren't going to skip a beat
they're one of the biggest beneficiaries
if you look at Amazon sales growth over
the last 20 years they've averaged
almost 25 percent of and you know if you
had told someone back then that was
going to happen well first of all no one
would believe it if in our world what
people do even today because they're
they're so value oriented they say okay
this innovators sales yeah they can grow
for twenty five percent for the next two
to three years then there will decay to
the GDP growth rate that's not what's
happening now the waves of innovation
that we're seeing and Amazon is the
first first proof of concept of this
idea that we could actually see some of
these companies grow at an exponential
rate and all that means is that they
will sustain some kind of super growth
number like 25 percent instead of
decaying according to the law of large
numbers right I think that I think I
think our portfolios are teeming with
that kind of stock and what we tend to
do during a period like this is we will
consolidate towards either our highest
conviction names or the stocks like I
mentioned to you that that are so
misunderstood in terms of there being a
solution to the problem so I can rattle
through if you'd like to meet a rattle
through by sector or industry now the
obvious beneficiaries which have done
very well Amazon just went out to a new
high today an all-time high so Amazon
and Netflix I would put tella doc and
zoom into this category
zoom despite its problems with privacy
and exposure to China in terms of having
its workers there they've been obvious
beneficiaries and people have flocked
and investors have flocked to them so
when when
that is happening in our portfolios
particularly in our flagship portfolio
we will be more opportunistic and use
those as cash sources in order to deploy
towards the much less well recognized
beneficiaries
so while zoom is very well recognized
you'll have companies like Z scalar in
the security space and pager duty in the
instant management space you'll have I
have some noted appear storage and
solid-state in the storage space the new
wave of storage though you'll have well
you'll have work day work day as well
understood but I think it's at a point
of accelerated shift as well because
it's moving and it's infiltrated through
HR departments and now it's moving into
financial and it's really getting at the
Oracles
and the sa P's of the world so again
what this is saying is the the the old
guard is going to lose share at an
accelerated rate beware those are the
companies that occupy the big that the
highest positions in the index funds out
there because they're the largest caps
is these newbies that are nipping at
their heels that have you know the
opportunity to be 10 baggers as we say
because they're not well recognized in
the medium part of this starting up I
guess part of this too is it's not just
the names right I think one of the
things that you're highlighting here is
it's also the strategy of you know take
a zoom everyone sees that it's working
everyone's piling in it's very easy for
there to be a bubble like mania in a
single name because it's the obvious
choice well it sounds like you guys are
doing is you actually start as that
rides and people recognize it you
actually start trimming a little the
position take that cash and then you go
look for what what's the next wave that
everyone's gonna realize oh that's a
beneficiary but if you can find those
before it you're gonna benefit obviously
from the growth that it will experience
right and the popularity of zoom is
going to feed these other infrastructure
players because we need the
infrastructure to support it right
so we owned a zoom and we owned it in a
small size though because the mark that
enterprise value to sales ratio is up at
I think at the time 50 times news crazy
for enterprise value to sales right that
includes the debt and everything and we
just said okay we'll put it in because
it certainly is disruptive and it is
taking share from the web Exodus and the
other more established but kludgy
players it's not really taking share
from teams which is Mike Microsoft but
they're broke both growing very rapidly
together but we sold it out when it just
took off as everything else was
plummeting and so that is where we will
make a valuation call like that saying
okay this this now everyone recognizes
is gone even further north in terms of
that valuation and look at these others
that are there to support it that are
being dumped right that's where it's
really interesting to because I think
that part of this of your strategy it's
not rocket science right it's basically
find the value before others recognize
it have the courage and conviction to
invest capital in those businesses and
then as other people realize that that's
an obvious winner or beneficiary whether
it's from the virus or some other sector
you benefit one of where I think you
really kind of went to bat and there's a
lot of people saying there's no way
you're right and all the stuff was Tesla
right and you guys were early and I
believe even when the price continued to
fall you continued to buy right like the
ultimate sign of conviction and you've
kind of been proven right to some degree
as we sit today maybe talk a little bit
about like that specific name and kind
of what you guys have seen there well
what's so interesting okay so at the
beginning of this year its soared to
almost $1,000 last May this time last
year it had dropped to 100 and it got
into the one
seventies and we were buying all the way
down and you know I often say I'm the
most trolled portfolio manager on
Twitter and I am in and because that not
because of me but because of Ilan and
that stock and all the shorts that were
who were supporting it and we had built
a very strong case it's a high as
conviction name still so but it's soared
to nine hundred plus we were taking
profits if we hadn't taken profits it
would have been a twenty to twenty five
percent of our portfolios which we
absolute cannot let happen we can only
buy up to ten percent so from a
psychological point of view what I like
to do when it goes above ten percent I
mean I like to let it ride certainly but
at some point like to take it down back
down to ten percent so that if it drops
from there remember we can't buy if it's
ten percent plus if it does drop from
ten percent though we can buy again
so I usually like to take it down to ten
percent and then it drops and it did it
dropped all the way down to three
hundred and fifty dollars in this crisis
and and why because the shorts were
saying aha even though they have eight
billion dollars in cash now they're
saying oil prices are crashing no reason
to buy an electric vehicle CrazyTalk
even though we've done we've done the
total cost of ownership with oil crisis
at this level it's still cheaper to own
an electric vehicle today now in a
sticker price basis maybe it'll take a
year or so but so we were buying all the
way down to 350 I can't tell you what
the mark was the last mark you never
catch the exactly the bottom we took
kept taking it back up to ten percent so
that's our style and now again I think
it's up to thirteen and a half percent
of our portfolio today because it's had
another nice move why is this move
happening it's happening because the
Bears who are typically Auto analysts
are seeing what their traditional auto
companies are
in this period in order to preserve a
six or seven percent dividend GM is
having to cut spending and where is it
spent cutting is spending electric
vehicles is cutting everywhere but
electric vehicles it's going to it's
going to fall even further behind Tesla
in terms of its EVG and we think there's
already two to three to maybe four years
behind probably four years behind and
we'll be going five years behind I think
it's becoming obvious to these Auto
Analyst finally how how long a lead lead
time Tesla has relative to the other
auto manufacturers and so and you know
they are in harm's way financially I
don't you know Ford eliminated its
dividend GM still keeping his dividend
my guess is it will go to and that will
continue to highlight you know Tesla
doesn't have a dividend 100% of its R&D
is an electric it doesn't have to share
with internal combustion engine engine
R&D which they still have to they they
still have to spend that money that's
the ninety five percent plus of their
fleets right and so we think Tesla
because of this crisis has gained even
more lead time here and I guess when the
oil prices crash like this the argument
that one Tesla is still cheaper right
it's kind of one component of it but but
it's really interesting to think about
Tesla actually gaining market share
even though oriole prices are crashing
right and it has more to do with what
the incumbents are not gonna do versus
what Tesla is doing it sounds like it's
just doing what they've been doing the
whole time it's everybody else starts
cutting back and therefore Tesla ends up
benefiting from a gaining market share
yeah if you using the first quarter
numbers so last year Tesla had 17
percent of the global the global evie
market including China which is the
largest market
now I think these are just us numbers
they could be global though by our
estimates in the first quarter Tesla had
30 percent market share yeah that's a
signal that's big leap yeah now those
are all crude and rough and you know
we're backing into all kinds of numbers
I know that's not the right number but
they have gained enormous share in in
this and and they're gaining enormous
share of total auto sales because total
auto sales went from let's see 17
million a year ago to eleven point four
in March and Tesla's sales on a
year-over-year basis now we only have
the total first quarter I think but I
think again I'm not not exactly right
their sales didn't drop by forty fifty
percent I think they went up by thirty
forty percent year-over-year
yeah it's pretty incredible and then I
guess this leads to kind of longer-term
rate one of the things that we talked
about last time
when we recorded was the idea of the
autonomous taxis right and you kind of
you know much farther out when I asked
for people that questions to send in for
you one of them was around this idea of
if that is the ultimate kind of end
state here and that's where a lot of
value gets created as well does it make
sense at any point over the short to
medium term for Tesla to create natural
ride-sharing app and start competing
with the ubers and lyft's of the world
or is it more continue to invest in R&D
continue to build out that actual
technology and then you back into the
fleet you know at some point in the
future well it's a great question from a
couple of angles first Tesla's ability
to produce is limited by the constraint
is management and so they need to build
out management and they are and so in
the meantime as they're revving up on
getting their management infrastructure
in place around the world Europe Asia
and so forth
here here Texas another one
we do believe that they are going to
start their own ride hailing service
Elon has hinted as such I think there
was a question on I think it was a
recent conference call but it could have
been a podcast where Ilan said yeah it
sounded like a good idea usually when he
says that done you know now the reason
it's also a very good question is I
think uber and lyft are in a world of
hurt here and the reason for that is the
way that business was beginning to
evolve is you are getting these
entrepreneurs who are saying okay I'm
gonna buy several cars here and and I'll
buy the cars all on them and populate
them with riders well guess what they
they were on shoestring margins probably
in the early days anyone in the early
days so a lot of them are going to be
out of business you know they'll lose
the cars and all of that that and that's
sad so there is an opportunity here for
Tesla to come in and what that will do
do two things that are very important
strategically for for Tesla one it will
increase their free cash flow it's a
very very profitable business relative
to their base business today which is
just producing cars that's that they're
just of producing cars is you know a 25
to 30 percent growth gross margin
business and this is probably that this
one if it were their own right ailing
service would be north of 50 percent the
way they would probably do it
interestingly would be to say to these
former entrepreneurs you know if you
give us five thousand down on a car we
will let you become a part of our fleet
and you can pay down that car by giving
us a percentage of your your fees the
the take rate it would be the take rate
the take
for uber and lyft is you know 25 to 30%
and we think that's going down we think
we think Tesla's take rate could be much
higher because these owners would be
paying down their cars overtime and
they'd be employed in this business so
it's a win-win for for both sides it's
also a win-win on in two ways for Tesla
one the free cash flow the second is
having a ride-hailing service out there
means they their collection of data will
go into overdrive you know they'll be
pushing cars out that drive 50 60
percent of the day instead of I Drive my
Tesla five percent of the day you know
so that I don't collect very many miles
per day for Tesla to inform it's AI deep
learning neural net systems whereas
these these these drivers would be
contributing a lot to the data yeah it's
super interesting another name that
you've been quite bullish on and
actually agree with is somewhat
underestimated is a square and what
they're doing in in the FinTech and
payment space maybe give us kind of your
thoughts I'm just like why so bullish on
that company that we could talk to some
of the intricacies or nuances of it yeah
and I'm gonna give a shout-out for to
max Friedrich who's our analyst and
we're just about to publish a white
paper on comparing venmo and cash app to
traditional banks and even to each other
you know
then Moe's a bit older than cash out and
and because of that cash app has some
advantages certainly in terms of its
agility and in terms of marketing
strategies and you know it's a it's a
more it's a younger it's a younger team
I would have to say and and we got a lot
of data you know from PayPal API you
know they they basically publish this
data so
it's a very rich white paper in terms of
learning about these ecosystems and
learning the competitive advantages that
both PayPal venmo and Kashyap have
relative to banks so in the case in the
case of square you know I just love it
because it it is really an abling you
know the lower income strata of this
economy anywhere from the lower income
to the highest income but really it's
much more meaningful to the unbanked and
if you look at where cash up really took
off first if you look at a map and you
compare it to an FDIC map of the
unbanked and underbanked part of the
United States you'll see the overlay is
almost an exact match and so that's how
it started and it started with these
mom-and-pop businesses really using the
square point-of-sale device to put on
top of their cellphone to actually do
business and so what can Square see
unlike a bank which can't maybe sees end
of month or end of quarter income
statements square sees every transaction
that this merchant may or has and can
see the cadence can see when business is
good when it's bad and what is some
starting to do now is say hey we see
that you're growing your business we can
offer you a working capital loan and
guess what you can pay that loan off as
your business you know daily you can pay
a bit off you know so it becomes a real
time oh we see you probably need more
employees hey we can help you with a
payroll service and then they will start
infiltrating a consumer base - which is
part of the employee base of this so
it's cash app gets added strength
because it's becoming part of a bigger
ecosystem that is proliferating first
through the south now it's moving up
we're seeing it move and
and you'll see on the maps how it is so
the competitive advantage that these
companies have relative to banks I think
is going to destroy banks it's going to
turn them into commoditized utility I
mean there will be there there will be a
reason for banks but it's not going to
be it's not gonna be the most profitable
reason there are four banks now the
other reason banks are gonna have so
much trouble if you look at the number
of digital users and include banks in
the United States the banks were doing
pretty well until cash app and venmo
started gaining critical mass now
according to our estimates this year
while venmo is already above above
JPMorgan which is something like more
than 40 million something like that and
and and cash app is not far behind in
fact we believe cash app will pass JP
Morgan this year as well
now how is this happening the banks have
the installed base that's always the
trap when you're talking about
innovation oh the old guard says that's
our market we're gonna wipe it these
newbies off the face of the earth we can
do that not so because the cost of
customer acquisition for cash up and pay
what PayPal is a fraction of that of the
banks banks have to pay to attract a new
checking account or a new credit card or
debit card somewhere between they have
to pay from a marketing and other costs
somewhere between 350 to $1500 per and
the reason they've been willing to go as
high as $1,500 is because these
customers typically have been very
sticky and their lifetime value has been
has been very lucrative for the bank's
today cash app and PayPal paid $20 think
about that $1500 versus $20 and the
reason for that is because of the viral
nature of cash app and then
you know if you're telling in the case
of I mean it's kind of funny if you took
a if you take a look at how quickly
social networks evolve so the Facebook's
and Google's of the world if you look at
cash out and and venmo they're there
their uptake is twice as fast as social
networking they're much more viral why
is that well for the social networks
Facebook Instagram today you know young
people don't really want their parents
to be following them right but when it
comes to venmo and cash up heck yeah
heck yeah come on mom come on dad and so
their parents are being forced into this
faster too and if you look at the
various cohorts cohort by court both the
younger groups and the older groups are
moving on to cash app and venmo twice as
fast as they moved on to social media so
this is becoming a big business and and
so I often say banks had these creatures
the venmo and cash out nipping at their
heels right and we can't even say
creatures and nipping they are you know
they are overtaking them in the digital
realm completely but if you even think
on the deposit side I know this crisis
will we'll change this to some extent
short-term but I don't think it will
change it long-term
you've got Marcus Goldman Sachs's Marcus
which you know they are really trying to
become they're trying to move into the
digital realm and take advantage of some
of the low cost of customer acquisition
like squaring cash out you know they
have been competing with the banks who
were offering maybe 50 basis points for
deposit accounts for a while there where
they were over three percent they're not
now but in order to make inroads they're
going to have to go for the jugular
of the banks and the jugular is that net
interest margin which is the difference
between what a bank gets on a loan and
what a bank has to pay on deposit
accounts which fund these loans so it
used to be huge before Marcus came
around and now Marcus and other newbies
I know Sophie and others are offering
even to date crazy rates relative to
what's offered in in the markets and
they're probably taking risk to do that
too yeah and I think one of the recent
reports you guys put out I think it was
the Big Ideas presentation for 2020 one
of the things I saw that was really
interesting was the market is valuing
the users differently as well right so
the idea that the bank customers are
getting valued at a premium to the cash
app or venmo users and ultimately you
you expect that it at least comes to on
par if not at some point the cash app
users and then what users are more value
so maybe talk a little bit about that
absolutely and very good you really dug
into big ideas not money dig that deeply
into it I read it every year it's great
thank you thank you yes so if you look
at what what investors I think it's a
bit different now after the crisis but
when we did big ideas at the end of last
year
investors were willing to pay three
thirty six hundred dollars roughly
dependent on the bank three thousand to
thirty six hundred dollars for each
deposit holder or a deposit account if
you look at each user in cash out of
cash up in venmo they're paying anywhere
for from $50 to a hundred and fifty
dollars we think so that would mean that
that the market the public equity
markets are paying 20 x plus four banks
when these guys are about to eat the
bank's lunch right and so it makes no
sense
and they're much more valuable models
also because of the morality they're
much more they should be valued more
like social networks than banks and yet
they're completely dismissed out there
and I think it's just because people
haven't they haven't done the homework
they don't really believe this yet you
can't say these these companies are too
small anymore they're they're they're
growing and they're growing very rapidly
so but I think it'll only be time and
and we'll catch up so that's why square
is in our top five in both our flagship
and our FinTech funds and actually our
next generation Internet fun yeah it's
really interesting I've told a story
before others but I've got a brother who
is I think 23 24 years old and one day I
asked him kind of jokey given a hard
time I said do you know a cent a bank
wire right and as you would expect his
responses what's a bank wire and I said
well how do you send money to your
friends and expected a venmo or cash at
type he's who I have two ways he said
ven Mo's one and then he said uber and I
remember thinking myself ooh BRR and he
said we out like when I get out of the
car
you know we split a ride basically like
uber does it for me yes and I was like
that really just highlights the
difference of how you know his
generation of kind of young 20s they
literally think of uber as a way to pay
their friends I think that most people
over the age you know 35 they've got no
clue that that's even a possibility let
alone that that's how a kid would think
about it absolutely if lubbers
underlying business weren't so bad you
know we'd probably be more interested in
that reason honestly I'll just make one
more give you one more thought very
relevant to your world you know cash app
has been so creative in marketing and I
think you know the cash app Fridays
where they give away one Bitcoin you
know and you can buy and sell Bitcoin in
the cash app it's pretty seamless you
know I and I believe this is one reason
Jack Dorsey was going to move to Africa
for a while I believe that this
is squares way of infiltrating the
emerging markets now they have an
extraordinary opportunity now because
what we say about innovation when it
comes to emerging markets is even more
true they have to usually run away from
disaster in terms of the loss of
purchasing power associated with their
currencies and Africa gets hit every
time and so to to bring Bitcoin into
that realm in a way that they're able to
you know I'm sure capital controls and
regulation will will present some
obstacles but to the extent they can
help salvage the purchasing power and
wealth of some of these individuals
Bitcoin with all its volatility was a
big last year it's up year-over-year
still I believe and and their currencies
have been smashed right and so I think
that squares way of infiltrating the
emerging markets it's been very
difficult there are a lot of obstacles
that develop the developed world puts up
as Square tries to migrate into Japan
and then to Australia it takes a long
time I think it could happen a lot
faster in the emerging markets and the
same is of course true with PayPal yeah
I can't let you go without talking a
little bit of Bitcoin you were obviously
one of one of the most bullish people I
think on Wall Street maybe let's start
with just what you guys have done with
your Bitcoin allocation over the last
you know month or two and then we'll get
into some of the other aspects of it
okay so I can talk about this in two
ways only one of our ETFs is holding
Bitcoin gbtc grayscale Bitcoin
investment trust and and you know there
are new instruments ones just launching
in Canada so we're analyzing we're doing
the compare and contrast there so we may
change things up a little bit on in
terms of the exact instrument but we
have added to it in its our
next-generation internet a or kW we've
added to it we cannot go and this is we
put our this is a limit we've imposed on
ourselves we cannot by above 2% and and
we're closing in on that now and the
reason for that is we if we do we risk
subjecting our shareholders to something
called unqualified income and I think I
mentioned it to you on our last podcast
together unqualified income if if more
it's not illegal but if more than ten
percent of a funds returns of the gross
profits is in unqualified income and in
this case just think of it would be like
commodity based income it's not
financial markets it's more CFTC
regulated so if more than 10% of our
gross profits is an unqualified income
then the IRS and these are realized
profits the IRS would be able to
confiscate everything above 10% now
what's what's the nightmare scenario
here say we're in a Black Swan event and
the fund drops by let's say it drops by
50% which was Oh 809 right that was some
funds dropped 50% and let's say Bitcoin
went up and it hit 10% of our portfolio
say it went up a hundred percent hit 10%
of our portfolio it would be generating
all of the profits and we could only
keep 10% of them mm-hmm in other words
and it's even worse because we would be
generating all these losses and of the
gross profits the gross this is not net
this is gross profits that Bitcoin would
deliver let's say it was up say went up
ten tenfold just i we don't get to keep
10% of that and we'd be realizing the
loss on the rest of the portfolio so
it's a little bit crazy than the rules
and regs
and hopefully they change over time in
our discretionary portfolios which are
not 40 act funds and where we can do
what we want
Bitcoin is about 5% of the portfolio we
bought during the swoon - the swoon from
well it was from it very quickly from
8,000 into the 3s so and and we're happy
there 5% I think I think that's good for
especially given what's happened to the
rest of the stock that we had we had a
big correction there as well so we've
had - we've had we've been doing a lot
of trading yeah and let's start with the
kind of Black Thursday if you want to
call it or whatever somebody's gonna
come up with some cute name for but
there was a drop of 50% in the Bitcoin
price you know a lot of people I think
that even the the strong hand holders
while they still held I definitely got
some phone calls so people were like you
know oh [ __ ] that this doesn't feel
great maybe you know kind of what was
your analysis Mike what happened there
and kind of how you guys thought about
that yeah I think the shock for a lot of
people is that we've been able to say
for so long that Bitcoin is uncorrelated
and here we were in the middle of a
difficult market for equities and we
were facing difficulties with this one
as well and many people who are in both
worlds were just probably a little
shaken up by that that was not supposed
to happen just it we didn't think it
would happen and so this notion that all
assets correlate to one in terms of
their performance now now we can say
applies to Bitcoin in a crisis it makes
a lot of sense a lot of the people
involved in Bitcoin run hedge funds we
are primarily a long only equity manager
so so it makes sense when when one
market is hurting the others will as
well as there are margin calls now what
I didn't noticed that was happening yeah
see in Elm Andhra whoo-hoo
I believe you're you know you know less
yeah yeah he at our brainstorm that week
went through the hundred times leverage
on this that in the other exchange and
and I I remember saying to I remember
saying to yes see and I said yeah seen I
know a lot about Bitcoin and and I also
am on the lookout especially during
during difficult markets for leverage
points who has the leverage who's going
to be forced to sell where the margin
calls going to be and I said but I
didn't know there was a hundred times
leverage out there anywhere and I said
is this common knowledge and he said it
is in the Bitcoin world but I think the
disconnect if I had to be honest about
it is those in the Bitcoin world that
became normal because these guys were
they were they could do no wrong they
were they could do no wrong you know so
and by the way in the equities market
over the years I've always learned
whenever I think I can do no wrong watch
out just watch out
start start taking the risk off right
because it's too easy that's what
happened and there were too many out
there who had net who were who were
leveraged to that extent who had no idea
what a bull a bear market would do to
them like to kill them they're dead now
I think there were good thing that's
happened about that is everyone knows
leverage is something you really have to
watch and you know even in terms of you
know our future plans we in terms of
using leverage in the crypto world you
know I I know what to do I've I've run
to hedge funds and and so forth but it's
very clear to me that the people who
were stuck I don't think they were the
sophisticated hedge funds they were the
individuals who got hooked and then
Minoo began to believe they could do
nothing wrong and then
or out of business I think it's a good
thing for the ecosystem that that that
understanding is look for the leverage
that's where your weak link is and you
can even you can even say that in the
various crypto asset ecosystems they all
learned a little bit more the governance
on some of these is excellent but they
are all learned a little bit more about
you know how to adjust their governments
to look out for that as a pain point as
a potential pain point and risk factor
which i think is good i think it's good
for the whole ecosystem yeah it's it's
one of those things where people don't
learn the lesson right and I think that
definitely happened and the other piece
too is a lot of the people that were
selling getting liquidated etc they're
not the long-term holders right that if
you look at most of the Bitcoin that
moved that day and kind of the weeks
before and after it's all things that
have moved in the last year right pretty
much that there's a bunch of people who
hold on to it and they believe is gonna
be a very binary outcome there's no
leverage there's no anything there's
passive holders and that number
continues to grow so I think generally
headed in the right direction this is
great it's great that there's data on
that because I know yes seen has
presented us with that chart who sold
the who sold all recent buyers you know
pretty much very very little by the
long-term holders absolutely and I guess
last question for you on Bitcoin before
you wrap up is the having is coming up
and one of the concepts that I've spent
a lot of time on recently and I wish
that I remember who came up with this
terminology but they said look if you
anchor on in the legacy world we're
having quantitative easing right kind of
the expansion of the balance sheets and
this liquidity injected we're about to
get quantitative hardening yeah in the
Bitcoin world and so maybe just some
thoughts on how about having should play
out given the macro backdrop but kind of
how you guys are thinking through that
yeah we had a big discussion about this
at our brainstorm last Friday and you
would be very welcome
actually your listeners are welcome in
you can we do have life size which is
the system I'm not sure how many we can
hand
but we are getting quite a few people
tuning in now and the concept was around
and what I loved about ya scenes kind of
presenting both sides you know he said
you know I'm kind of I don't know I I'm
not sure which side I fall out on here
my I have a very simple approach and
Brett went in our director of research
as well weighed in and and we went back
and forth on it and I think just in a
very simple way from given the backdrop
the economic backdrop that we have has
when this having and I don't know if you
call it having or happening but when it
takes place and and the rate of
inflation is cut in half there are two
things that that will have happened one
another very important software update
in the ecosystem right without Forks and
and just at least that I know about and
to the you know no intervention despite
what's going on in the rest of the world
where everyone's intervening to throw
everything they can at a problem no
intervention that 21 million is so that
will be another another proof of concept
that this is going to happen no matter
what is going on in the rest of the
world I mean if there were developers so
inclined they could have said look you
know we can't we can't do this in the
face of what's going on no no you must
do it in the face of what's going on out
there this is the proof of concept so
from my point of view it'll be a very
positive event now a lot of I was in the
camp for a while as people were talking
about that having and and saying okay
this is gonna be a very bullish case and
the price was lifting and we got into
the 12,000 or wherever we got then I was
thinking okay this is gonna
the the it's taking place now typically
these you discount these things ahead of
time but with this you know those
eruption in in the market in the Bitcoin
space as well I I think y'all Dulles is
going to be a positive event and you
know it's what it's the end of May is it
like May 11th to 13th somewhere in there
ok mid mid May I think it should be a
positive event you know I don't know why
it wouldn't be I can't imagine a reason
it wouldn't be unless unless the
software you know unless something goes
wrong with the underlying technology
which I highly doubt yeah what I think
I'm personally looking at is you get all
the QE not just here in the US but also
you know Japan trillion dollars kind of
a bunch of liquidity just being injected
in the in the global financial system
over time people just like we saw in
2008 l-29 assets sold off and in that
kind of liquidity trap and then
eventually people went for the inflation
hedges right and through oh nine ten and
eleven gold obviously which had sold off
thirty percent no eight ended up doing
very nicely hit a new all-time high and
what if that happens again
right which structurally and kind of
sequentially is likely to happen I think
to some degree if it does it's going to
coincide right around the same time that
you get that happy right so to some
degree would be like everyone looking
for gold and half the gold miners in the
world shutting off at the same time
alright and seems bullish but again we
kind of have to watch this play out and
see you know does the having actually
occurred as the code executes you know
in kind of does the macro backdrop
execute as well and we'll see you know
having met some of the key or the core
developers I had the privilege of
meeting a number of them last year and
I'm I I was so impressed so impressed I
would be shocked if something went wrong
with the software and the resolve to Hue
to the 21 minutes the cadence all of
that there I I was as
said my confidence in Bitcoin went up
dramatically after I met them because
you know before that I kind of thought
you know these these are these are kids
who have never seen any crisis and
that's not true that's not true there
are some I was able to have a solid
economic discussion with a number of
them I mean deep economic theory in a
way that I never imagined and that's
because there are gray hairs among there
are young but then there are gray hairs
people very committed to this so I was
struck by that and my conviction and
Bitcoin went up enormous Lee after that
so and I will say it's gone up I was a
little like this hundred times leveraged
what the heck and and and seeing Bitcoin
disconnect from gold itself I was saying
okay there's something wrong here and
and that's when we had the brainstorm
session I mean we Yassine had mentioned
it but the brainstorm session was about
leverage and then the halving and you
know what would the net-net be so I
think you know where we come out on this
absolutely Elissa Kathy I really
appreciate taking the time to do this
people are really really excited to kind
of hear your thoughts on a whole bunch
of this stuff you guys have done a
fantastic job I think not only one I'm
kind of presenting all the information
and research which people find valuable
but obviously too as I like to say the
scoreboard you know kind of proves it
for itself has done a great shot there
as well so just for everyone else thank
you for for doing this stuff where can
people go find either information or
where would you like to send them if
they want to learn more about arc and
and kind of your process and reports
yeah so arc - or - invest calm is our
research site yes all right well we will
definitely have to do this again I think
that people love to hear from you
whenever you want to do it so thanks so
much thank you thank you very much it's
a fantastic forum because you know what
you really like to dive deeply into what
we're doing and that's the only way you
can understand how profound some of the
innovation
platforms we're researching are I mean
they're going to deliver exponential
growth for years and you are really
doing your viewer base and an incredible
service well I'll leave you with one
thought which was I saw somebody
tweeting saying tell Cathy to go on CNBC
more she can't let Jim off have all the
fun so if people will love the the hot
takes there as well if you want to go do
okay well thank you thank you I much
prefer this form thank you take care